This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之二。这是当旁边有自动扶梯时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些磨难，你将会浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即数字的2%。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at it》播客节目中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每集我们都会选择一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。84年是一个疯狂的年份。那是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Today is International Women's Day and I thought what better way to celebrate than to bring my mom on the show to discuss my motherhood, feminism being a leader, a successful woman in a male dominated industry, all of the above. She is a pretty cool lady and my personal hero. I know that sounds cliche, but I am super lucky to have had such a wonderful role model, who has a lot of wisdom to share, and I thought you guys could benefit from some of that
在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。大家好，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个探讨我们在20多岁时面临的一些重大生活变化与转变，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。今天是国际妇女节，我想，有什么比邀请我妈妈上节目，来讨论我的母职、女性主义、作为领导者、作为男性主导行业中的成功女性等所有这些话题更好的庆祝方式呢？她是一个非常酷的女士，也是我的个人英雄。我知道这听起来像是个陈词滥调，但我真的很幸运，能有这样一位拥有丰富智慧、值得学习的伟大榜样，我想你们也能从中受益。
wisdom as well. This episode is part of IHeart's International Women's Day Initiative called Women Take the Mic. You can find a bunch of other interviews just like this one, searching women take the mic wherever you get your podcasts. Let's jump into the interview. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we break down the psychology of our 20s. Today we're going to be doing something a little
这份智慧同样适用。本集是iHeart国际妇女节倡议“Women Take the Mic”的一部分。你可以在获取播客的任何地方搜索“women take the mic”，找到许多像这样的其他采访。让我们直接进入采访。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友、老听友，无论你身在世界何处。非常高兴你能回来收听另一期节目，和我们一起剖析20多岁的心理学。今天我们要聊点稍微
bit different. I know I say that every guest is my favorite, but honestly this one I think kind of has to take the cake by obligation because they are blood. I thought it's International Women's Day today who better to talk to who is more my hero than my own mother. So today I'm bringing on my mom to come and have a chat with me. So we talk about mother daughter dynamics, motherhood, being a successful woman in business as she is and feminism and all the good things that come with it. So hey mom. How you going? Hey, Jim. You were saying to me that you were nervous before this.
不同的东西。我知道我每次都说某某嘉宾是我的最爱，但老实说，这一次由于血缘关系，我认为这个头衔非我妈莫属。我想今天是国际妇女节，还有谁比我自己的母亲更适合交谈、更配得上我的英雄这个称呼呢？所以今天我请我妈妈来和我聊聊天。我们要聊母女关系、母职、像她一样在商界成为一个成功的女性，还有女性主义以及与之相关的所有美好事物。所以，嘿，妈妈。你好吗？嘿，吉姆（Jim）。你刚才跟我说你在这之前很紧张。
I'm a bit nervous. Why? Because I probably haven't been, well, I haven't been interviewed by you before. No. It's a different dynamic. And of course, you know, I want to do well by you. Oh, my God. You want to impress the listeners?
我有点紧张。为什么？因为我可能还没被，嗯，我以前没接受过你的采访。没有。这是一个不同的动态。当然，你知道，我想在你面前表现好点。哦，天哪。你想给听众留下好印象？
Well, I just, I don't want to let you down. I don't want to come across as not being worthy of your wonderful pod. Oh, that's okay. I'll defend you to the death. If anyone says anything, I'll be like, that's my mother you're talking about so block deleted. I honestly think this will be a great chat because we have a good relationship, both as a mother and daughter and as kind of friends as well.
嗯，我只是，我不想让你失望。我不想表现得配不上你这个精彩的播客。哦，没关系。我会誓死捍卫你的。如果有人说什么，我会说：‘你谈论的可是我母亲。’所以直接拉黑。我真心觉得这会是一次非常棒的聊天，因为我们关系很好，既是母女，也有点像朋友。
Yeah, me too. I'm looking forward to it. It's just a different dynamic for me. Yeah, I'm in charge. Yeah, you're in my turf. I can't hang up. You can't hang up. We're blood-related.
对，我也是。我很期待。对我来说这只是一种不同的动态关系。对，我是老大。对，这是我的地盘。你不能挂电话。你不能挂电话。我们有血缘关系。
So I wanted to bring you on because obviously it's International Women's Day. And I was thinking, let's do a special episode. for this. Let's do an episode talking about what it means to be a woman, to identify as a woman. And part of what comes with that is also like a discussion around like our relationship with our mothers and a relationship with our parents and all these other things, how like our childhood informs the women that we grow up to be. And I thought that we could do a little deep dive into what it was like for you to become my mom because I'm the, eldest daughter. You're also the eldest daughter. And just like what I was like as a child,
所以我邀请你来，是因为显然今天是国际妇女节。我在想，我们为这个节日做一期特别节目吧。做一期探讨身为女性、认同为女性意味着什么的节目。而随之而来的部分，也包括围绕我们与母亲的关系、与父母的关系以及所有这些其他事情的讨论，比如我们的童年是如何塑造了我们成长为什么样的女性的。我想我们可以深入探讨一下你成为我妈妈的经历，因为我是长女。你也是长女。还有我小时候是什么样子的，
what it was like becoming a mother, like I said, and then what it's like to run a business, basically, which you do. Well, you're a CEO. So what that's like? Well, certainly plenty to talk about. Yeah. I'm going to start with a hard-hitting question. Okay, go for it. Because I wanted to know this as well. What was I like as a child? Do you remember? Be embarrassed if you don't. No, the funny thing is, you really do remember. And I suspect that there's, I need to be a bit careful because, of course, memories change over time
正如我所说，成为母亲是怎样的体验，然后像你一样经营一家公司又是怎样的体验。毕竟你是一位CEO。那是什么感觉？好吧，确实有很多话题可以聊。好的。我要以一个尖锐的问题开始。好吧，尽管问吧。因为我也想知道这个。我小时候是个什么样的孩子？你还记得吗？如果你不记得那就尴尬了。不，有趣的是，你真的记得。我猜，我需要小心一点，因为，当然，记忆会随时间而改变，
and you think you remember certain things. I'm sure you remember some things differently to the way I remember them. We can get to that. But actually, the really interesting thing is when I sort of think back on you and your sisters, I've got really clear memories of the days each of you were born, my sort of very clear first impressions of each of you
而且你以为你记得某些事情。我确信你对某些事情的记忆和我对它们的记忆有所不同。我们待会儿可以聊到这个。但实际上，非常有趣的是，当我回想起你和你的妹妹们时，我对你们每个人出生的那几天有着非常清晰的记忆，对你们每个人最初的第一印象也非常清晰。
and it's funny, you're all different. You're, I remember, so what I remember of you, the day you were born, and by the way, you had to come in, you know, with a bang, you were an emergency Caesar child. So there was that. Caesar? There was that. But the thing I remember was in amongst all of this sort of calm chaos
很有趣，你们各不相同。你，我记得，我记得你出生的那天，顺便说一句，你以一种轰动的方式降生，你是一个紧急剖腹产的孩子。所以是这样的。剖腹产？是这样的。但我记得的事情是，在所有这种平静的混乱之中，
was you sort of coming out with these big eyes, just sort of slowly blinking at the, the world as if to say, you know, where am I and what have I come to, but not, not crying so much and just sort of, you know, trying to sort of focus straight out of the gate, trying to focus on what was around you and trying to make sense of it is what it felt like. I can't remember that, but. Yeah, and then, you know, you were quiet as a little baby for the first week or so, but that changed.
你睁着一双大眼睛出来了，只是慢慢地对这个世界眨着眼睛，仿佛在说，“我这是在哪里，我来到了什么地方”，但你没有哭得很厉害，只是，你知道的，试图一出生就聚焦，试着关注你周围的事物，并试图理解它，当时的感受就是这样。我不记得那个了，不过。是的，然后，你知道的，作为小婴儿，你在第一周左右很安静，但后来情况就变了。
But the other thing, too, is that I think the other really strong kind of recollection for me was that very early on you realise that your kids come out with their own personalities. And because I too had done a bit of psychology in my time, I think there's that whole nature versus nurture sort of thing that goes through. And I think you start off thinking, you know, you're going to be this amazing parent and it's all going to be nurture. But, you know, probably because you were our first, it was a pretty overwhelming kind of sense of,
但另一件事是，我认为对我来说另一个非常强烈的回忆是，很早的时候你就意识到，你的孩子生来就有他们自己的个性。而且因为我也在我的年代学过一点心理学，我觉得其中贯穿着先天的自然与后天的培育这种争论。一开始你可能会觉得，你知道，你会成为一个了不起的父母，一切都靠后天的培养。但是，（也许）因为你是我们的第一个孩子，那种感觉相当压倒性，
oh, this little person has come out, you know, with a set, with their own sense of who they are, their own personality. And then what were you like as a kid? You know, you were strong-minded. Oh, that hasn't changed much. No, it hasn't. But you were. You really had strong views even as a youngster.
哦，这个小人儿带着一套他们自己的身份认知、他们自己的个性降生了。那么你小时候是什么样的呢？你知道的，你很有主见。哦，那倒没怎么变。不，确实没变。但你的确很有主见。你甚至在很小的时候就有强烈的观点。
But you were happy. And as a first child for us, the biggest thing was you were a sleeper. And my golly gosh, we love that. That's so cute. I love that you said, I came out and I was quiet for the first week. and the irony being now I literally talk on the internet for my job, which is so funny. And I am a bit of a yapper, obviously. I love a yarn.
但你很开心。作为我们的第一个孩子，最棒的事在于你很会睡觉。天哪，我们太喜欢这样了。太可爱了。我喜欢你说我出生后第一周很安静，而讽刺的是，现在我工作就是靠在互联网上滔滔不绝，这太有趣了。显然我有点像个话痨。我喜欢聊天。
I love a yarn. You were just a quiet little muleau when you were just a wee little baby. And I was your favourite, obviously, for the first five years at least. Well, yeah, as Bart and I say, you're our favourite oldest daughter. Yeah, that's so diplomatic. I still think that you all have a favourite, you just can't say. And I think that I'm yours. hopefully my younger sisters, hopefully Ellie and Hannah aren't listening.
我喜欢聊天。你当小婴儿的时候只是个安静的小不点。而且显然在前五年里我是你最喜欢的。好吧，是的，正如巴特（Bart）和我所说，你是我们最爱的长女。是的，太外交辞令了。我依然觉得你们每个人都有一个最爱，只是你们不能说。而且我觉得我就是你的那个。希望我的两个妹妹，希望艾莉（Ellie）和汉娜（Hannah）没有在听。
Yeah, well, I'm going to assume they are. Yeah, I'm sure they are. So this is the thing. I feel like, how old were you when you had me? You were 32, right? 33. 33. Okay.
好吧，我姑且假设她们在听。对，我确信她们在听。所以这就是问题所在。我觉得，你生我的时候多大？你32岁，对吧？33岁。33岁。好吧。
So you were like well into your 30s, but you were like my age, like nine years older than I am now. Yep. And that's like insane to me to think that I would be ready to have a child in nine years. like, let alone in like 15. What was like the biggest lesson you learned having children? Did you actually always want children even when you were younger? Yeah, I always wanted kids even when I was younger. You know, it's interesting because like 33 is, you know,
所以你当时已经三十多岁了，但你就像我这个年纪，比现在的我大九岁。对。这对我来说简直疯狂，想到我九岁之内就要准备好生一个孩子。更不用说15年内了。你生孩子学到的最大教训是什么？即使在你更年轻的时候，你其实也一直想要孩子吗？是的，我甚至在更年轻的时候就一直想要孩子。你知道，这很有趣，因为像33岁，你知道的，
it's not young to be having kids. Yeah. In the spirit of total frankness, you know this. It took us a while to get pregnant with you. I don't need the internet to know that. Yeah, well. But it's, you know, and it's just, It is one of those things that, you know, we were keen to have kids.
生孩子并不算年轻。是的。出于完全的坦诚，你知道的。我们怀你花了一段时间。我不需要互联网来知道这一点。是的，好吧。但是，你知道，而且，这就是其中一件事，你知道的，我们渴望有孩子。
You know, life, you find your partners at whatever age. Other things kind of happen. And, you know, I think one of the things that I was thinking about in terms of this conversation was how people think about when to have kids. And, you know, for me it was when I met your dad. And, you know, we went overseas and did some things. And then came home to Australia and we're keen. to start a family and you know we feel blessed to have three kids but it's not always a straight line
你知道，生活嘛，你在什么年纪找到伴侣。其他事情也会发生。而且，你知道，我认为我在这次谈话中思考的事情之一，是人们如何看待什么时候生孩子。对我来说，那就是当我遇到你爸爸的时候。而且，你知道，我们去了海外做了一些事情。然后回到澳大利亚，渴望开始一个家庭，你知道，我们觉得生了三个孩子很受保佑，但生活并非总是一帆风顺。
I definitely felt very ready to be having kids but it comes with a lot of you know a lot of ups and downs too and things that you don't know what happens through pregnancies and whatever and so yeah we you know was I ready I was but then in some ways I guess you're never ready because you never know what's going to happen and that's part of the the challenge is the uncertainty of it all was it harder when we were younger or is it harder now? Now that we're, because a lot of us, well, I flew the nest pretty young. I left to her when I was like 17. But Ellie and Hannah are like getting to the point where they're about to leave.
我绝对觉得自己非常准备好生孩子了，但这也伴随着很多，你知道，很多的起起落落，还有那些你不知道在怀孕期间或其他时候会发生的事情，所以是的，我们，我准备好了吗？我是准备好了，但在某些方面我想你永远不会真正准备好，因为你永远不知道会发生什么，这也是挑战的一部分，就是这一切的不确定性。当我们更小的时候更难，还是现在更难？现在我们，因为我们中的很多人，嗯，我很早就离巢了。我17岁左右就离开家了。但艾莉和汉娜正处于即将离开的阶段。这会让人觉得，
Has it been, that, has that been difficult being like, oh, am I no longer having that role that you've had for 24 years? I think it's, it's one of the other things you do learn when you have kids and maybe I think about this because, you know, you know, I was a working mum for, were big chunks of, you know, your younger life and your sisters as well, and particularly, you know, when you were in primary school. And I think there's a sense that when kids are really young, they really need their parents. And they do for certain things. But, you know, I found when you were in high school and your sisters, as they've gotten older, that you continue to
这会很困难吗，比如，“哦，我不再拥有你这24年来所扮演的角色了吗？”我认为，这是你生孩子时学到的另一课，也许我想这一点是因为，你知道，你知道，在你的童年和妹妹们的童年里，有很大一部分时间我是个职业妈妈，特别是，你知道的，当你读小学的时候。我觉得有一种感觉，当孩子们还很小的时候，他们真的很需要父母。在某些事情上确实如此。但是，你知道，我发现在你上高中以及你的妹妹们长大的过程中，你会继续
need your parents, but in different ways and for different things. And that sense changes. But I kind of thought that, you know, there was times when you guys were in high school, for instance, where you needed your parents around just as much as you did when we were in primary school. And so I think that's maybe one of the, I don't know if myths is the right word, but there's so much focus on, you know, being there for kids when they're younger. And actually, I think the pressure is there all the way through and just being clear about that and recognising you have to try to find a way to be there for your kids no matter what else is going on. It's just one of the, you know, one of the challenges, but also one of the great joys of being
需要你的父母，但方式不同，需要的方面也不同。这种感觉会变。但我曾认为，你知道，在你们上高中的时候，有些时候你们需要父母在身边，就像我们在小学时一样。所以我认为这也许是，我不知道“神话”是不是合适的词，但有太多焦点放在了，你知道，在孩子小的时候陪伴他们。实际上，我认为这种压力一直存在，只要弄清楚这一点，并认识到无论发生什么，你都必须努力寻找方法去陪伴你的孩子。这只是其中一个，你知道，其中一个挑战，但也是成为父母的巨大乐趣之一，
a parent when you feel like you're doing that. And hopefully your kids think you're doing that. Well, it's so interesting because I feel like for a lot of, like my teenagers, I didn't really need you. Well, at least I thought I didn't need you. And then as soon as I went to university and then actually, like, probably the second year of university, like the first year I really was like, I don't need my parents. Like, I am a big girl. I am an adult now. I live independently. And then it was like, oh, you get older and it's like the reversal. And you're like, oh, my gosh, I really need my mom. And I'm like, oh, I really, like, it's kind of coming back to the nest. Like, it's such a big thing in your 20s that you fly the nest and you go off and you do your own thing. But then I think that the further along
当你觉得你正在这样做的时候。希望你的孩子们也认为你在这样做。这太有趣了，因为我觉得对于很多，比如我的青少年时期，我其实并不需要你。好吧，至少我以为我不需要你。然后一上大学，实际上，大概是在大学第二年，就像第一年我真的觉得，“我不需要我的父母。我是一个大女孩了。我现在是一个成年人了。我独立生活了。”然后就变成了，哦，你长大了，这就变成了一种反转。然后你会想，“哦，天哪，我真的很需要我妈妈。”然后我就觉得，哦，我真的，这有点像回到巢穴。在你的20多岁，离巢并去过你自己的生活是一件大事。但随后我认为，沿着这段旅程走得越远，
on that journey, the more you're like, actually I want to come home. And like, and I want to see my parents. and I want to call my parents. And I remember it was like my first, like, big heartbreak when I was at uni that I was like suddenly so much more rely on you guys in a way that I didn't feel like I had been since I was a kid. Yeah, I mean, I think you all, you know, I've seen it in your sisters as well. Of course you go through phases of where you really, independence is really important to you. And it's the actual independence.
你就会越觉得，实际上我想回家。而且，我想见我的父母。我想给我的父母打电话。我记得我在上大学时经历第一次重大心碎时，我突然变得比小时候更依赖你们了。是的，我的意思是，我认为你们所有人，你知道的，我也在你的妹妹们身上看到了这一点。当然，你会经历一些阶段，在这些阶段中，独立对你来说非常重要。这就是实际的独立，
and I think it's the perception of independence as well. But I think, you know, from my perspective, just being around sometimes is important then. So, you know, because I think it allows you to sort of go off and live your life, but knowing that if you need it, it's there. And even if you don't necessarily acknowledge it, I think there's a sense that, you know, your parents can provide a bit of a foundation. And, you know, if you do need to come back or need support, we're there. but it's, you know, the flip side is it's fantastic as a parent to see your kids going off and doing that.
而且我认为这也是对独立的感知。但我认为，从我的角度来看，有时候陪伴在身边在那个时候很重要。所以，你知道，因为我认为这让你能够去过你自己的生活，但你知道如果你需要它，它就在那里。即使你不一定会承认它，我认为有一种感觉，你知道，你的父母可以提供一些基础。而且，如果你确实需要回来或需要支持，我们都在那儿。但硬币的另一面是，作为父母，看到你的孩子们走出去做那些事情真是太棒了。
And then, yeah, hopefully at different stages, the perception or whatever of that independence becomes less important. And that's the whole thing about your relationship kind of ebbs and flows and evolves. And it's, yeah, it's a nice thing. What's been the hardest part about being a mother? Yeah, it's a good question. I mean, I think in all honesty, it's the sort of vulnerability and the, uncertainty of it. Like you just, you know, with a partner, there's an element of it.
然后呢，对，希望在不同的阶段，那种独立的感知什么的变得不那么重要。这就是关于你们的关系如何起伏、演变。而且，是的，这是一种美好的感觉。作为母亲最艰难的部分是什么？对，这是个好问题。我的意思是，老实说，我认为是那种脆弱感和不确定性。就像你，你知道的，和伴侣在一起时，其中包含某种成分。
But when you, you know, when you have kids and you just love them so much and care for them so much, it's that, you know, watching them go out into the world and the equal measure of wanting them to be independent and, you know, excited and exploring the world and doing everything that you did, but, you know, also sort of probably having a greater understanding of all the things that can go wrong and just that balance of just, you know, there's always just that little bit of fear. You never want harm or sadness or anything to come to your kids, but that's not the way they can live their lives. So it's just that uncertainty and it's, you know, it brings great excitement and emotion and joy. But every now and then, you know, you're white knuckling in a bit.
但当你，你知道的，当你有了孩子，你如此深爱他们，如此悉心照料他们，这就是，你知道的，看着他们走向世界，既希望他们独立、兴奋、探索世界、做你做过的一切，但又，你知道的，可能对所有可能出错的事情有更深刻的理解，以及那种平衡，你知道的，总是会有那么一点点恐惧。你绝不希望你的孩子受到伤害、悲伤或任何不好的事情，但他们不能那样生活。所以这只是一种不确定性，它，你知道的，带来了巨大的兴奋、情感和喜悦。但偶尔，你知道的，你还是会有点捏一把汗。
Really? It's so interesting because I even feel that way towards Hannah and Ellie, like my sisters, where Ellie is going to uni and I think about what my first two years of uni are like and I want her to have those experiences but I also know like how chaotic and sometimes awful they were and I'm like maybe I'll just protect you from them like maybe you could just be a little girl
真的吗？太有趣了，因为我对汉娜和埃莉也有这种感觉，就像我的姐妹们一样，埃莉要去上大学了，我想象着我上大学头两年的经历，我希望她有这些经历，但我也知道它们是多么混乱，有时甚至糟糕透顶，我就想，也许我会保护她不受这些伤害，也许她可以当一个小女孩
a little baby for a little bit longer and like not have those that independence and I'm like I feel that towards my sister I can't imagine what that would feel like as a mother being like I give birth to this child who was now like doing like off in the world and I like don't know what they're where they are don't know what they're doing at all times what was like an experience where you said you were like white knuckling it oh it's you know there's well I don't know you go overseas um and you know
当一个小宝贝再久一点，不要有那种独立性，我就觉得，我对妹妹都有这种感觉，我无法想象作为一个母亲会是什么感觉，觉得我生下这个孩子，现在却在外面闯荡，而我却不知道他们在哪儿，不知道他们在做什么在任何时候，有什么经历让你觉得自己捏了一把汗？哦，你知道的，有很多，我不知道，你出国了，然后呢，你知道的
I'm thinking about that time I was in Amsterdam and I called you and was like I'm dying possibly and I wasn't even like on anything I wasn't I know the connotations of like being in Amsterdam I was just like really tired and I was like I'm dying I've decided like my anxiety and I called you guys like three a.m well and it was it was the um you know it was that like maybe white knuckling's the the wrong way to describe it but there is a certain sense that when your phone rings in the middle of the night you know once you've had kids that that has a certain like you leap to you can leap to the wrong conclusion and so your your heart starts racing um you calm yourself down but then You know, there was an element of, do it would have been nice if you'd phone the next day
我想起我在阿姆斯特丹的那次，我给你打电话说，我可能快死了，我甚至没有碰什么东西，我不是，我知道在阿姆斯特丹那种地方的含义，我只是真的很累，然后我说我快死了，我决定了，我的焦虑，我给你们打了电话，大约凌晨三点，而且是，那是，你知道的，也许“捏一把汗”是错误的形容方式，但确实有一种感觉，当你的电话在半夜响起时，你知道的，一旦你有了孩子，那就会有一种，你会跳到，你会得出错误的结论。所以你的心开始狂跳，你让自己平静下来，然后呢，你知道的，如果第二天你打个电话
to remind us that you were okay. No, no, that's not how it works. I was too, so I was 18 and selfish. I wasn't going to let you guys know I was okay. But the other thing too is just the emotional sort of stuff and the emotional hurt. And so that's why, you know, white knuckling's not the right term. But you do expose yourself to feeling it. And, you know, you've experienced it yourself.
提醒我们你没事，那就更好了。不，不，事情不是这样的。我当时太年轻，而且很自私。我才不会让你们知道我没事。但另一件事是情感上的那些东西和情感上的伤害。这就是为什么，你知道的，“捏一把汗”并不是正确的词。但你确实让自己去感受它。而且，你知道的，你自己也经历过。
But then to watch other people who you care about go through some of that stuff, which is just, it's just life. But, you know, it's not easy to see other people go through that and to be sad or to be, you know, to be hurt. And in some ways, really the emotional stuff is harder than, you know, going to get the stitches or whatever else. And, you know, we've had conversations about this that, you know, we try to do the right thing.
但随后看着你在乎的人经历其中的一些事情，这只是，这只是生活。但是，你知道的，看别人经历这些，感到悲伤或，你知道的，受到伤害并不容易。在某些方面，情感上的东西实际上比，你知道的，去缝针或其他什么更难。而且，你知道的，我们讨论过这个，你知道的，我们试图做正确的事。
We tried to raise each of you as independent people who could make their own decisions and who were resilient. to those challenges. And sometimes it meant, you know, letting you find your way a bit and I'm sure that felt hard. And it was hard to watch but, and experience as well. But you've got to, you know,
我们试图把你们每个人都培养成能够自己做决定、并且有韧性面对这些挑战的独立个体。有时这意味着，你知道的，让你自己去摸索，我确信那感觉很艰难。而且看着和经历也很艰难。但是你必须，你知道的，
it's always trying to walk that line of doing things that, that, you know, trying to be the parent that sets you up for success in your future, which sometimes, you know, comes across as, you know, not necessarily being the kindest or most protective parent at different stages when you're younger. I know exactly what you're referring to. And I remember being in primary school and all of the people, all of my friends had these like helicopter parents who had a drop of the hat would be there to fix things for them and you guys were not those parents. You were like, oh, you're having problems at school? Great. Go and talk to your teacher. Deal with it. Like, not that callous. You weren't
它总是试图走那条线，做那些，你知道的，努力成为一个为你未来成功做好准备的父母，有时候，你知道的，在你们年轻的不同阶段，这看起来并不一定是善良或最具保护性的父母。我完全知道你在指什么。我记得在上小学的时候，所有的人，我所有的朋友都有这种直升机父母，他们随时准备着为他们解决问题，而你们不是那样的父母。你们会说，哦，你在学校遇到麻烦了？太棒了。去和你的老师谈谈。自己解决。就像，倒也不是那么冷酷。你们不是
like deal with it like get out of our face we don't want to hear from you but it was like that thing where I did have a point where I was like gosh I wish that my mom was just like a bit more angry on like on my behalf and I'm sure you were but you were like and now I'm super grateful for the fact that you made me be a problem solver and independent because it's I think a big part of my personality but that was definitely times where I was like gosh I do just want my mom to scream at someone for me well there were times when can I just say that little bit of independence, which usually your dad let you exercise more than me. There were moments when I similarly went to pick you up from childcare and thought,
那种“自己解决，滚出我们的视线，我们不想听你废话”的态度，但就是那种，我确实有过一个时刻，当时我想，天哪，我希望我妈妈能更生我的气，我确信你们是这样的，但你们当时表现得像，而现在我超级感激你们让我成为一个能解决问题的人并且独立，因为我认为这是我性格中很大的一部分，但那确实有几次我想，天哪，我真的只想让我妈妈为我大声责骂某人。不过有那么几次，我能说那点独立性吗？通常你爸爸比我更让你去行使它。有那么几个时刻，我同样去托儿所接你，心里在想，
what is she wearing or what is she doing? And then packing your own lunch that had its highs and lows as well. Oh, yeah, what did I pack? Junk food? Well, just fair few crackers. Yeah, duh. I was a growing girl. I was hungry.
她穿的是什么，或者她在做什么？然后自己打包午餐也有起起落落。哦，对了，我都打包了些什么？垃圾食品？好吧，就只带了不少饼干。对，废话。我当时是个长身体的女孩。我很饿。
I was sharing them. I don't know why. So this is like a hot, hot question, but you have three daughters. Did you ever want a son? Yeah, it's so interesting, isn't it? Look, I think you always, I think you always sort of think, oh, you know, one of each, you know, at least like having one of each in the family, not necessarily just two kids, but yeah, I think you do, but can I be really honest and say, well, for starters,
我还在跟别人分享。我不知道为什么。所以这是一个非常热门的问题，但你有三个女儿。你曾经想要个儿子吗？是的，太有趣了，不是吗？听着，我想你总是，我想你总是会想，哦，你知道的，儿女双全，你知道的，家里至少有一个男孩和一个女孩，不一定非得只有两个孩子，但是，是的，我想你是会这么想，但请允许我坦诚地说，首先，
I reckon with every one of my pregnancies, at least at one stage, someone told me that I was having a boy. And no one ever told me I was having girls. But like with you, we were walking down the street in Fitzroy one morning. And this Italian nonna came from across the street. Like walked, you know, 100 metres from across the street came up to me and said, it's a boy. So that was pretty funny. And when I was pregnant with Hannah, I definitely thought she was a boy just because she behaved so. differently in the womb to the rest of you because she was a little pocket rocket in there.
我估计我的每一次怀孕，至少在某个阶段，有人告诉我我要生个男孩。而且从来没有人告诉我我要生女孩。但就像你一样，有一天早晨我们在菲茨罗伊的街上走着。一个意大利老奶奶从街对面走过来。就像走过来，你知道的，从街对面走了100米来到我面前说，是个男孩。所以那挺有趣的。当我怀着汉娜的时候，我绝对以为她是个男孩，仅仅因为她在子宫里的表现与你们其他人太不一样了，因为她在里面就像个小火箭筒。
But so after you and, like, after you and Ellie, I have to say my greatest fear was that I was going to have a boy because I was like, okay, I've got two girls now. I think I understand them. And a boy is just going to like throw me off now. Yeah. But I think it's, this is going to sound like such a cliche. but, and in all honesty, because after you were born, like, you know, the whole, the emergency seizure thing was a moment. And at the time, it was, you know, our doctor was fantastic.
但是呢，在你之后，就像，在你和埃莉之后，我必须说我最大的恐惧是我会生个男孩因为我想，好吧，我现在有两个女孩了。我想我懂她们。而一个男孩现在只会把我搞得不知所措。是的。但我想这是，这听起来可能是一句老生常谈的话。但是，老实说，因为在你出生之后，就像，你知道的，那场紧急剖腹产是一段经历。而在当时，那是，你知道的，我们的医生非常棒。
But when I looked back, I thought, wow, that was a moment. And from then on, you do just sort of think, well, I'm just, I just feel blessed to have healthy kids, you know, so that's the truth of it. So I, you didn't know what gender, did you, was it a surprise? All three, yeah. No way. I didn't. know that? Yeah. Oh, that's so cute. And the funny thing is that each time around we had three
但当我回想起来时，我想，哇，那真是一个时刻。从那时起，你确实会想，好吧，我只是，我只是觉得自己有健康的宝宝就很幸运了，你知道的，所以这就是事实。所以，你不知道性别，对吧，这是一个惊喜吗？三个都是，对。不可能。我不知道？对。哦，太可爱了。有趣的是，每一次我们都有三个
names for boys, but only one name for a girl. So they knew. Someone in the, someone in the universe knew. So that's actually really interesting. I had no idea. But I do also think you didn't have sons, but you raised us like sons. I, I've said this since I was like younger. I'm like, you guys raised us like boys in a very like traditional stereotypical way that people raise children like boys just letting us get into so much mischief we were always dirty i'm pretty sure i only wore boys clothes for a long time buzz light your t-shirt buzz light your outfits honey don't just say t-shirts you were the full kitten caboodle yeah well i was a super fan i was i was i was a stand i loved that man yeah but yeah i just feel like there was so many ways that you guys kind of did raised us
男孩的名字，但只有一个女孩的名字。所以他们知道了。宇宙中的某个人知道了。所以这其实真的很有趣。我一点都不知道。但我也觉得你们没有生儿子，但你们把我们当儿子养。我，我从年轻时就这么说。我说，你们把我们当男孩子养，用一种非常传统、刻板的方式，就像人们抚养男孩子那样，只是让我们去闯祸，我们总是弄得很脏，我很确定我在很长一段时间里只穿男孩子的衣服，巴斯光年的T恤，巴斯光年的套装，亲爱的，别只说T恤，你可是全套装备齐全。是的，好吧，我是个超级粉丝，我是个，我爱那个男人。是的，但，是的，我只是觉得有很多方式，你们确实把我们抚养成人了
without like an idea of gender like i maybe i'm just being remembering things the way i want to remember them, but I don't remember having dolls. I think also it was the fact that maybe like the gender stereotypes were less. You're lying. You're lying now. Come on. Really? What doll did I have? Oh my goodness. Come on. What did you use to do to your Barbies? Oh, I used to, I made weird Barbie. I used to cut all the hair off. Yeah. And their fingers as well. I want the extra mile. You definitely, I don't remember the fingers, but you definitely were queen of the Barbie haircut. These were punk rocker barbies. Yeah. Here we go. I think one of the things, too, that I've come to, really appreciate and you know you make the decisions you do in terms of work and life and all
没有那种性别观念，就像，也许我只是在按照我想要的方式记事，但我不记得我有洋娃娃。我想这也是因为可能性别刻板印象比较少。你在撒谎。你现在在撒谎。得了吧。真的吗？我有什么洋娃娃？哦，天哪。得了吧。你以前对你的芭比娃娃做什么了？哦，我以前，我做了奇怪的芭比。我把所有的头发都剪掉了。是的。还有她们的手指。我还做得更绝。你绝对，我不记得手指的事了，但你绝对是芭比理发店的女王。这些都是朋克摇滚芭比。是的。开始了。我想，我也非常感激的一点是，你知道的，你在工作和生活以及其他所有方面做出了你的决定
the rest of it but I've really come to the view that the fact that your dad's you know spent a lot of time at home with each of you and it was very clear for you I think from my perspective and I think it's because there were fewer men in the playground at the time but having a father at home he let you take more risks. There's no doubt about it. And he was much more comfortable with that. And there are so many times, you want to talk about white knuckling actually,
其余的，但我真的得出的看法是，你爸爸，你知道的，花了很多时间陪你们每一个人，而且从我的角度来看，这非常清晰，我认为这是因为当时操场上的男人较少，但家里有一个父亲，他让你承担更多的风险。毫无疑问。而且他对此要舒服得多。有那么多的时刻，如果你想谈谈捏一把汗的话，其实，
watching you race to the corner of the footpath on your bike every time as you just scream down the street on your bike, I just used to think, oh my gosh, I hope she stops in time. And it's the same for each of your sisters. But, you know, Bart was just he let you guys, you know, jump and run and climb and, you know, he was famous in the, I mean, I remember coming around the corner of the playground at the school and seeing all of the mums kind of standing in a semi-circle with their mouths open and I knew what was going on and it was Bart standing there throwing
看着你每次骑着自行车在街上尖叫着冲向人行道拐角，我以前总是在想，哦天哪，希望她能及时停下来。你每一个姐妹都是这样。但是，你知道的，巴特只是，他让你们，你知道的，跳跃、奔跑、爬树，你知道的，他在学校里很有名，我的意思是，我记得走到学校操场的拐角处，看到所有的妈妈们都围成一个半圆，张着嘴，我就知道发生什么了，那是巴特站在那里把
kids in the air and they had this kind of half happy, half-terrified look on their face and it just so explains the difference of, you know, I think how you guys were raised. Well, it's true because dad was a stay-at-home dad for most. of our childhood. I know there was a period where you were, you stayed at home, but you were still working, but he was like a full stay-at-home dad. And I know I'm talking about you, but there was definitely moments that I remember being a kid where he faced a lot of discrimination for that whilst you probably also faced a lot of discrimination for being a working mom. Like, neither of you had it easy to kind of subvert the gender norms. The one I always think of is
孩子们抛向空中，他们脸上带着那种半高兴、半恐惧的表情，这正好解释了不同之处，你知道的，我认为你们是怎么被抚养长大的。嗯，这是真的，因为在我们的童年时期，爸爸大部分时间都是全职爸爸。我知道有一段时间你是，你呆在家里的，但你还在工作，而他就像是一个全职爸爸。我知道我在谈论你，但绝对有那么几个时刻，我记得作为孩子，他为此面临了很多歧视，而你可能也因为作为一个职业妈妈而面临了很多歧视。就像，你们俩谁也没有轻易地去颠覆性别规范。我总是想起的那件事是
the time that that woman wouldn't let her daughter come over because, she thought he was a sex offender or something like that. It was someone who, yeah, did, I won't repeat it because it was illegal. It was illegal, yeah. And it was. But yeah, he faced that. It was, yeah, he faced that. But equally, I'm not sure if you remember this.
那个女人不让她的女儿过来，因为，她以为他是个性侵犯或者类似的人。那是一个人，是的，做了，我不会重复，因为那是违法的。那是违法的，是的。而且确实是。但是，是的，他面对了这一点。这，是的，他面对了这一点。但同样地，我不确定你是否还记得这个。
This was when I went to, when I just started this period. So this is about five years when I was predominantly the stay-at-home parent. You were in high school by then, but your sisters were in primary school. And I remember going to a birthday party that one of Ellie's friends was having and we were at, you know, that indoor playground. And I arrived to the party and the woman who was hosting it, you know, sort of said to me, oh, you know, who's your child? And I said, oh, Ellie.
这是在我去，当我刚开始这段时期的时候。所以这是大约五年前，我主要扮演全职家长的时候。那时你已经上高中了，但你的妹妹们还在上小学。我记得去参加埃莉的一个朋友举办的生日派对，我们在，你知道的，那个室内游乐场。我到达派对现场时，主办派对的女人，你知道的，有点对我说，哦，你知道的，哪个是你的孩子？我说，哦，埃莉。
And she said, well, she goes, oh, are you, are you Barts' wife? And I said, yes. And she said, oh, and all along I just thought he was. was this lovely single dad. Oh my gosh. And I just thought, it's so embarrassing for her. Oh, it's just, it was just really brutal. And I thought, what, and what do I think about all your mums who come and pick your kids up?
她说，嗯，她说，哦，你是，你是巴特的妻子吗？我说，是的。她说，哦，我一直以为他是个可爱的单亲爸爸。哦，天哪。我当时就觉得，这让她太尴尬了。哦，这真的，真的很残忍。我想，什么，那我怎么看所有来接你们孩子的妈妈们？
And so it just, it spun both ways. Yeah, it really did. Yeah, but I'm glad that it happened that way because I feel like we got a really unique childhood. And now it's so much more common. But back then, like, it was so weird, like early, early 2000s to see like a stay-at-home dad. Oh, it was just, it was, it was a tough gig, it was in both ways, like, it was very hard for him, very lonely, to be honest.
所以它朝两个方向旋转。是的，确实如此。是的，但我很高兴事情是这样的，因为我觉得我们有了一个非常独特的童年。现在这已经很常见了。但在那时，就像，在2000年代初看到一个全职爸爸是如此奇怪。哦，这简直，这简直是一份艰难的工作，在两方面都是，这对他是非常艰难的，老实说，非常孤独，
But, and look, I don't, you know, I'm not trying to say it was better or worse for either of us, but it was, you know, it was equally frustrating if you'd rock up in the school yard to, you know, I'd drop you off at school and I'd be in a suit and on my way to work and people would stop and ask me if I was coming to the book reading at 11.30. and, you know, in contrast, the dads who were dropping off in their suits, no one, everyone knew where they were going, they were all going to work, and they didn't get, they got praise for making time to drop their kids off, and they weren't asked, you know, are you going to stay longer? And it sounds like a small thing, but there was always a bit of, it was hard not to feel a little bit of guilt. Yeah, or like, feel like they're being like, oh, you're like a failure as a mother
但是，听着，我不是，你知道的，我不是想说这对我们俩谁更好或更坏，但是，你知道的，如果你出现在学校操场上，同样令人沮丧，你知道的，我送你上学，穿着西装，在去上班的路上，人们会停下来问我是不是要去参加11点30分的图书朗读会。而且，你知道的，相比之下，那些穿着西装送孩子的爸爸们，没有人，每个人都知道他们要去哪儿，他们都是去上班，他们因为抽出时间送孩子而受到赞扬，而他们不会被问到，你知道的，你要呆更长时间吗？这听起来是一件小事，但总有一种，很难不感到一点内疚。是的，或者感觉好像他们觉得，“哦，你作为一个母亲是个失败者
because you're not sticking around and we are. Because I haven't, I haven't made the time. that. It was, it just felt like that was the message. Here's the thing. I don't remember a single book reading. So I don't think it mattered that you weren't there. You were there for the important things. Yeah, well, I think, I hope that that's the case. But regardless, you have to, you make the, you make the decisions that have to work for, you know, your family. And it's a combination of a whole bunch of things. And it's, you know, you've got to have income and, you know, ideally you have a house to live in and financial security and you know you've got to you just
因为你没有留下来，而我们留下来了。”因为我没有，我没有抽出时间来做那件事。这感觉就像是那个信息。事情是这样的。我不记得有任何一次图书朗读会。所以我觉得你不在场也无所谓。你在做重要的事情时都在场。是的，好吧，我想，我希望是这样。但无论如何，你必须，你做出，你做出必须为，你知道的，你的家庭起作用的决定。这是许多事情的结合。而且，你知道的，你必须有收入，你知道的，理想情况下你有一个可以住的房子和财务安全，你知道的，你必须，你只需
make those choices and they're not set and forget you kind of ebb and flow with that but i think the hard the hard part and the thing you probably get a bit more perspective on when you get a bit older is that those opinions don't really matter and um yeah you've got to you've got to glide past them a little bit and know that you're making the best decisions that you can you know and there's no you're never going to do it perfectly well well that kind of leads to next question. Do you think you made any mistakes? Would you do anything differently? Did we make mistakes? 101 mistakes. Yeah, name a couple. I want something to blame you about. I want something to hold over your head. Well, there's, there's, I don't know, there's lots of little
做出这些选择，它们不是一成不变的，你会随之起伏，但我认为困难的部分，当你年纪大一点时可能会有更多感触的事情是，那些意见其实并不重要，嗯，是的，你必须，你必须对它们略加忽视，并知道你正在做出你所能做出的最好决定，你知道的，而且没有，你永远不可能做得完美。嗯，这差不多引出了下一个问题。你觉得你犯过什么错误吗？你会做任何不同的事情吗？我们犯过错误吗？有一百零一个错误。是的，说几个。我想找点事情来责备你。我想把一些把柄抓在手里。嗯，有，有，我不知道，有很多小
things. You go back and you, you know, partly you say things or you phrase something in a particular way and you, you know, you don't think about it, but it lands, it gets heard in a particular way. and, you know, when your kids recount things back to you, you didn't mean it that way or you didn't, the context, you saw the context differently. There's 101 little things like that and, you know, all sorts of stuff. And I don't look back and think that there's one major thing that we did, you know, we had, but you know that you didn't get everything right.
事情。你回过头去，你，你知道的，部分原因是你说了某些话或用某种特定方式表达了某些事，然后你，你知道的，没有多想，但它落下了，被以某种特定的方式听到了，而且，你知道的，当你的孩子们把事情向你复述时，你并不是那个意思，或者你没有，你对语境的看法不同。有一百零一个这样的小事情，你知道的，各种各样的事情。我不回顾过去并认为我们做过什么重大事情，你知道的，我们有，但你知道你并没有把一切都做好。
and whether it was what you did or the tone that you did it with in the time, you just know that. But would you do anything differently? I think that's a hard, I mean, in some ways I think it's a hard question or even a harsh question because, you know, you do the best that you can at the time.
无论是你所做的事还是你当时说话的语气，你只是知道这一点。但你会做任何不同的事情吗？我认为这是一个艰难的，我的意思是，在某些方面我认为这是一个艰难的问题，甚至是一个严厉的问题，因为，你知道的，你在当时已经尽力了。
And, you know, I think one thing that's very hard on parents, if I'm honest, is that there's so much else going on. There's so much other context that your kids don't know about. And nor should they. But it does mean that sometimes, you know, you come home from work, there's been a lot of stuff going down. There's a lot of stress or anxiety related to other things that you don't necessarily want to share with your kids. But it does inform some of the decisions you make or how you communicate them.
而且，你知道的，老实说，我觉得对父母来说很难的一点是，有太多其他事情在同时发生。还有很多孩子们并不了解的其他背景。他们也不应该了解。但这确实意味着，有时候，你知道的，你下班回家，发生了许多事情。有很多与别的事情相关的压力或焦虑，你未必想跟孩子们分享。但这确实会影响你所做的一些决定，或者你如何向他们传达这些决定。
And at the time, you know, I don't think your kids appreciate it. When you grow up, I think you do. But, yeah, that's all in the mix. On a lighter note, I'll give you an example. Yeah, tell me. Ellie teases me all the time because I'm not sure if you remember this, but I used to sing songs to you guys when I was putting you to bed. And Ellie in particular always just wanted to sing along.
而且当时，你知道的，我不觉得你们会感激。等你长大了，我想你会的。但是，是的，这些都交织在一起。换个轻松点的话题，我给你举个例子。好啊，告诉我。艾莉总是取笑我，因为我不确定你还记不记得，但我以前在你们睡觉前给你们唱歌。尤其是艾莉，总是只想跟着一起唱。
Aw, she's so cute. She's still like that. But I just wanted it to go to sleep. And so she teases me now about the fact that I would be quite firm on the, like, no, you're not to sing the songs with me. And she says, you're singing all these cute songs. songs and all I wanted to do was sing along, but you would say, no, you've got to go to bed now. So maybe on reflection I would have done that differently.
啊，她太可爱了。她现在还是这样。但我当时只希望（你们）去睡觉。所以她现在拿这事取笑我，说我当时态度很坚决，像是“不行，你不能跟我一起唱”。她说，你唱着所有这些可爱的歌，而我只想跟着一起唱，但你会说，不行，你现在得去睡觉了。所以也许回想起来，我会用不同的方式处理这件事。
That's, that's so cute because it's like, I forget that although we each like grew up together, we, I'd never heard that. Like, we had such different memories of like our interactions with you. That's so cute. Oh my God, she's adorable. I'm going to say, yeah. She also, well, I mean, so here's the other thing. So I'm trying to get her to sleep because Hannah, of course, didn't sleep at all.
这、这太可爱了，因为感觉就像，我忘了虽然我们是一起长大的，我们，我从来没听过这个。就像，我们对和你互动的记忆竟然如此不同。这太可爱了。天哪，她太招人喜欢了。我得说，是的。她还，我的意思是，所以还有一件事。所以我当时在哄她睡觉，因为汉娜，当然了，一点觉都不睡。
And so when she's recounting these stories, like we're in year one of the five-year stage of, you know, youngest daughter not sleeping through the night. I'm going to ask you a few more questions around motherhood. And I want to ask whether you think that you were a feminist mother, not just a feminist, but were you a feminist mother. So this is a really interesting question for me because for a couple reasons. One, because I actually think I've become more of a feminist as I've gotten older. And if I think about it in the context of not just being someone who believes in equal rights and lives that way and hopefully raises their girls that way and I'll come back to it. But I'd probably be a bit critical of me in terms of being.
所以当她讲起这些故事时，就像我们正处于小女儿整晚不睡的五年周期的第一年。我要再问你几个关于为人母的问题。我想问你是否觉得自己是一位女权主义母亲，不只是女权主义者，而是你觉得自己是一位女权主义母亲吗？所以这对我来说是一个非常有趣的问题，原因有几个。第一，因为我实际上觉得自己随着年龄的增长，越来越有女权主义意识了。如果我从这个角度来思考——不仅仅是一个相信平等权利、以这种方式生活并希望以这种方式抚养女儿的人，我待会儿会回到这一点——但我可能会对自己作为……
a really strong advocate for other women. So I think in the way I lived in the things I did, but if I think about, you know, feminists being an advocate and a really strong advocate for all women, I'm not sure I'd give myself a huge score on that, to be honest. I'd look back and think I could have done more or have been more vocal in different circumstances. But in terms of how I raised being a feminist mother,
其他女性的坚定倡导者这一点，进行一番自我批判。所以我想，从我的生活方式和我所做的事情来看，但如果我想到女权主义者意味着成为所有女性的倡导者和一个非常坚定的倡导者，老实说，我不太确定自己在这方面能得高分。我回过头来看，会觉得自己在不同的情况下本可以做得更多，或者可以发出更多声音。但就我如何把这作为女权主义母亲来抚养孩子而言，
Yeah, I think so. Yeah. And I think, you know, in terms of being an advocate for each of you, both as individuals but also as girls and young women, yeah, I do think so. Yeah, I would say so as well. I do think that like this, but the brand of feminism that we had when we were younger was very white feminism. But I think also that was like just what was there at the time. I always think about like Hillary Clinton as like an example
是的，我想是的。而且我认为，就成为你们每个人的倡导者而言，无论是作为独立个体，还是作为女孩和年轻女性，是的，我确实这么认为。是的，我也会这么说。我确实认为，就像这个，但我们年轻时拥有的那种女权主义是纯粹的白人女权主义。但我也觉得，那只是当时存在的状况。我总是想起希拉里·克林顿作为一个例子……
but I also think that like it's just like the process of unlearning your white feminism in a way especially like where we lived you know we lived in like in Australia in inner city Australia where like the discussions about like intersectionality weren't being
但我也觉得，这就像是一个剥离你身上白人女权主义的过程，特别是像我们曾经生活的地方，你知道，我们住在澳大利亚，内城区的澳大利亚，在那里，关于交叉性的讨论……
had back in like 2000 like the early 2000 But now I feel like you're such a good example. Also, I feel like you're not giving yourself enough credit there. Like you being an advocate, I think you did a lot more than most other people. Think about all your friends. Like, you have so many strong female friends who you advocate for in so many ways. Yeah, look, I appreciate that.
在2000年左右，也就是2000年代初期，根本没有展开。但现在我觉得你就是一个很好的例子。同时，我觉得你在这里有点太低估自己了。就像你作为一个倡导者，我觉得你做的比大多数其他人都要多。想想你所有的朋友。比如，你有那么多强有力的女性朋友，你在很多方面都为她们发声。是的，听着，我很感激。
There's just some things I've learned on the way through and some things in leadership roles where if I was being honest, you know, I think I could have done more. or maybe I came late to some of the things that I should have been, you know, doing more of and being much more supportive and more demonstrably supportive, I think, and just recognising the importance of that over-demonstration of being a champion or a supporter of people, not having it be sort of implied or assumed. How do you think that our relationship has changed as I've become an adult? Do you think we've gotten closer?
只是有些事情是我在经历中慢慢学到的，有些在领导岗位上的事情，如果说实话，你知道，我觉得我本可以做得更多。或者我可能有点姗姗来迟，未能做更多我本该做的事情，没能给予更多、更显而易见的支持，我认为，只是认识到超越表面的示范、成为人们的拥护者或支持者的重要性，而不是让这种支持停留在暗示或假设中。你觉得自我成为成年人以来，我们的关系发生了怎样的变化？你觉得我们变得更亲密了吗？
Yeah, no, I definitely think so. But I think it's one of those things that, yeah, I don't know. Like, it's just a different type of closeness, right? Like there's maybe a weird word, but there's an intimacy with your kids when you're younger and a closeness and a dependency that, that's, you know, that's really close, right? And, and a lot of fun in that. And that, you know, that fun piece is a closeness that's pretty unique to that younger state when your kids are younger.
是的，不，我绝对是这么认为的。但我觉得这是那种，是的，我不知道。就像，这只是一种不同类型的亲密感，对吧？就像“亲密”这个词可能有点奇怪，但当你和年纪较小的孩子在一起时，有一种亲密感、依恋感和依赖感，那（种感觉）真的很亲密，对吧？而且其中有很多乐趣。而且，你知道，那种乐趣也是一种相当独特的亲密感，存在于孩子还小的那个阶段。
And it's, it's just lovely. But, you know, as your kids grow older and certainly with you, you know, being able to have grown up conversations and, you know, what I think it is is being able to experience and appreciate that respect. And, you know, there's not a lot of people that you go through life with where you just really look at them and think, I really respect who you are as a person. And, well, and I've got, you know, I feel lucky to have a lot of really good friends who I do really respect, but there's, you know, there's not that many people. And anyway, it's fun to sort of have been a part of that and to have seen you grow up. and then to have so much respect and appreciation and admiration for what you've done.
而且，这真的非常美好。但是，你知道的，随着孩子们长大，尤其是对你而言，你知道的，能够进行成人的对话，你知道的，我认为这就是能够体验并体会到那种尊重。而且，你知道，你这一生中一起走过的人并不多，你看着他们会真心觉得，我真的很尊重你作为一个人本身的品格。而且，好吧，我有，你知道，我觉得自己很幸运，有很多真正的好朋友，我确实非常尊重他们，但是，你知道，这样的人其实并不多。不管怎样，能够成为其中的一部分，看著你长大，然后对你所做的事情充满尊重、感激和钦佩，这真的很有趣。
And I guess, to be honest, if I'm being a little bit egotistical, you sort of feel like you're a little bit of part of that. And it's very special. I do like to give you guys a lot of credit, I will say. I don't want too much. It's just that little bit where you sort of like, every now and then, yeah, she's mine. Do you? Yeah.
我想，老实说，如果我稍微有点自负的话，你会觉得自己也参与了其中一点点。这非常特别。我确实很喜欢给你们很多功劳，我得这么说。我不想居功至伟。只是有那么一小部分，你会觉得，偶尔，是的，她是我的女儿。是吗？对。
I think dad does it more than you do. No comment. Oh, diplomatic. Do you find it weird when, you know, when I was like in my, as I got into my early 20s, did you find it weird when I would talk about my relationships or like sex or anything like that? Was that weird? Because I feel like there was a point where it kind of, yeah, I don't know. I was like, am I treating my mom more like my friend or like my mom?
我觉得爸爸比你做得更多。无可奉告。哦，真外交辞令。当，你知道的，当我在20岁出头的时候，如果我谈论我的恋爱关系或性之类的话题，你觉得很奇怪吗？那会很奇怪吗？因为我觉得有过那么一个阶段，它有点，是的，我不知道。我在想，我是把妈妈当成朋友对待，还是把她当成妈妈？
Yeah, I didn't find it weird. I mean, occasionally there was an early podcast that, uh, I'm not sure if you remembered this, but you said something along the lines of, oh, my parents might be listening. And I jokingly was saying, yeah, I rang you up and said, yes, I'm listening, which, you know, of course was not contemporary, but nonetheless. So every now and then there's maybe a bit, you know, too much information. I think the hardest part is that I was probably, I'm very close to my mum, your grandma, you know that.
是的，我不觉得奇怪。我的意思是，偶尔在早期的一期播客里，呃，我不知道你还记不记得，你说了类似“我的父母可能在听”这样的话。我开玩笑说，是的，我给你打电话说，是的，我在听，当然，这并不是实时的，但不管怎样。所以偶尔可能会有一点，你知道的，信息过载。我觉得最难的部分是，我可能，我和我妈妈——也就是你的外婆——非常亲密，你知道的。
And we probably share more information now. but when I was younger, so it was me and my brother, but I had a stepbrother and a step-sister and that sort of mixed marriage. And, you know, my mum and my stepfather were sort of off kind of building their own life together. And the easiest thing for me to do was just, you know, play my cards close to my chest.
我们现在可能会分享更多信息。但在我小时候，家里只有我和我哥哥，但我还有一个继兄和一个继姐，这是一个重组家庭。而且，你知道的，我妈妈和继父当时正忙着建立他们自己的生活。对我来说最简单的做法就是，你知道的，把底牌捂紧。
So I didn't share a lot of information. It wasn't really letting anyone know what I was up to live in my own life. And like you, I was at uni when I was 17. And so, and then, you know, my parents moved into state. So I was lucky, lucky you're really independent, but in a kind of flip scenario, if you like. And so I probably wasn't sharing as much as information. And, you know, I think it was just getting used to what you were prepared to sort of share as well. It wasn't that it was right or wrong or I felt uncomfortable.
所以我没有分享太多信息。其实没让任何人知道我在忙些什么、过着怎样自己的生活。而且就像你一样，我17岁就上大学了。所以，然后，你知道的，我父母搬到了外州。所以我很幸运，庆幸你真的很独立，但却是一种截然相反的情况，如果你这么看的话。所以我可能没有分享那么多信息。而且，你知道的，这只是需要习惯你愿意分享的程度。并不是说那是对是错，或者让我感到不舒服。
It was just different to perhaps the way I had been at that age. And so just a bit of getting used to that. Yeah, it's so interesting. Are there things you don't want to hear? Maybe There's maybe a bit of dating information that Before the not to be named
这只是和我当年那个年纪的做法有些不同。所以需要一点时间去适应。是的，太有趣了。有什么是你不想听到的吗？也许，在那个名字不能提的……
boyfriend arrived on the scene I I went a little bit Whilst not wanting to look uninterested It was a bit la la la in my brain I feel like I'm very good where I'm like I don't talk about them by name
男朋友出现之前，我……有过那么一小阵子。虽然不想表现得漠不关心，但我的脑子里其实是一片“啦啦啦”的状态。我觉得我处理得挺好的，就是那种——我不会直呼其名地谈论他们……
Or introduce you until it's like serious Like Until we've been dating for at least six months So I feel like my current boyfriend, just not even my current, my boyfriend will be for a long time. Just kind of like popped onto the scene. And then you guys, I think I mentioned him and then you met him like a month later. Yeah, that's fine. It's more, I mean, if I'm being really honest, it's not that.
或者把他们介绍给你，直到事情变得严肃起来，比如直到我们已经约会了至少六个月。所以我觉得我现在的男朋友，甚至不是现在的，是我会交往很久的男朋友。就好像是“砰”的一下突然出现在生活中。然后你们，我觉得我提到了他，然后你们在一个月后就见到他了。是的，没关系。更准确地说，如果我说实话，并不是那样。
It's more the more casual relationships. Oh, you didn't approve. It's not that I didn't approve. I just didn't need to know about that. Yeah. I'm just going to say this for the listeners. The information that I was giving my mom was like, oh, a man was at my house last night. And you'd be like, no, he was not true. That's not true. The funny one was when I picked you up on a Saturday morning because we were flying back to Melbourne for Grandma's birthday. And you were furtively texting someone in the back seat of the Uber. which was the person who was still at your place. Did you know that? Well, yeah, because you ended up having to tell me
更像是那些比较随意的恋爱关系。哦，你当时不赞成。倒不是我不赞成。我只是不需要知道那些事。是的。我得为听众们说一下。我当时给我妈透露的信息是这样的：“哦，昨晚有个男的在我家。”然后你就会说：“不，他才没有。”才没有呢，那不是真的。最搞笑的是有一次星期六早上你接我，因为我们要飞回墨尔本给外婆过生日。你却在优步的后座上鬼鬼祟祟地给某人发短信。而那个人当时还在你家里。你知道这事吗？嗯，对，因为你最后不得不告诉我……
because I couldn't figure out what all the texting was going on about. Yeah, that was, oh my God, I completely forgot about that. Oh, yeah, that's so true. That did happen. And the thing was, you know what it was, was, it was actually not good because my house where I'm moving out literally today. But my current house, once you're in the house and the door is locked, you can't get out without a key. And it's metal bars all over the windows, all over the doors.
因为我搞不懂你一直在发什么短信。对，那是，天哪，我完全把这事忘得一干二净了。哦，对，太真实了。确实发生过。而且事情是这样的，你知道是怎么回事吗，其实挺糟的，因为我当时住的房子——我literally今天就要搬走了。但当时那栋房子，你一旦进了屋把门锁上，没有钥匙就出不去。而且所有窗户、所有门上都装满了铁条。
And all of the doors were locked and there were no keys in the house. And my roommates weren't coming back until that evening. So I accidentally locked that man in my house for eight hours before he could get out. And I was, and I was like, we were running late for our flight. I was like, and well obviously he's not around anymore so I'm not going to say you're going to be like sorry but can you imagine if he was listening sorry I locked to in my house for eight hours that's so funny that's so funny 2% that is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available I'm Michael Easter and on my podcast 2% I break down the science of mental
所有的门都锁上了，屋里连一把钥匙也没有。我的室友们直到那天晚上才会回来。所以我阴差阳错地把那个男的锁在我家里锁了八个小时，他才终于脱身。而且我当时，我们赶飞机快迟到了。我就想，而且显然他现在已经不在我身边了，所以我不用担心你回头会说……抱歉，你能想象如果他也在听的话吗？对不起，我把你锁在我家里八个小时。这太搞笑了，太搞笑了！百分之二，这是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。我会与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，带大家看穿主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾以为种子油天生具有炎症性。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会迎来一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。
toughness fitness and building resilience in our strain modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled healthier person. Listen to 2%.
就在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金的胸部吗？或者坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back At It》播客中找到答案。
That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选你……剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过这段日子的。包括最近一期邀请马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，畅谈80年代的可卡因。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊一整天可卡因，只是让大家知道一下。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here. unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know.
我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二期节目了，所以我开始看出这里有一条主线了。我们现在还把艾滋病摆上了台面，所以。谢谢你把话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black. people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years from black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get
真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back At It》。
your podcasts. Business. I want to talk about work because I was very lucky that I had a mother like you who was very, very independently successful. No Nepo babies here. You worked very, very hard, but you also had a very unconventional way to success. Like you got you know, it was crazy to hear when I first went to uni that you actually got asked to leave your university. You got kicked out from the economics department and now you are an economist and you are a very good economist and you're also a CEO. What do you think were some of the hardest parts about breaking into that male dominated industry? Well, first of all, let's not just slide over getting kicked out of uni because I do actually think it's, an important message. I think there's so much pressure on people at high school and in their
事业。我想聊聊工作，因为我很幸运能有你这样一位非常、非常独立且成功的母亲。这里可没有靠拼爹妈上位的星二代。你工作非常、非常努力，但你通往成功的道路也极其非主流。比如你，你知道的，当我第一次上大学时，听说你竟然被大学劝退，这让我觉得太疯狂了。你被经济学系开除了，而现在你是一名经济学家，还是一位非常优秀的经济学家，同时你也是一位首席执行官。你认为打入那个男性主导的行业，最艰难的部分是什么？好吧，首先，我们不要轻描淡写地略过被大学开除这件事，因为我其实觉得这是一个很重要的信息。我认为现在高中生和20多岁的年轻人面临着太多的压力……
20s around, you know, going to uni and just doing everything. Getting amazing grades, you know, paying for a life that's more and more expensive by the day, you know, and doing all the extracurricular stuff so that you end up with a CV that gets you into a job that you want, right? And I just think there's just so much pressure on, I think, and to understand where you're going and what you think you should be doing. So I actually make a point of talking about the fact that it took me, you know, quite a few years to get through a uni. I was fortunate, it didn't cost what it costs you guys now.
关于上大学以及把所有事情都做好。取得惊人的成绩，你知道的，去支付一天比一天昂贵的生活开销，你知道的，还要做所有的课外活动，好让你的简历能帮你找到一份心仪的工作，对吧？我只是觉得，在弄清楚你要去哪里以及你觉得自己应该做什么方面，真的有太多的压力。所以我其实特意强调过这样一个事实：我花了相当多的我很幸运，它没有你们现在花的那么贵……
But I did fail two years of university because I had no idea what I wanted to do. So I actually started off doing a psychology degree, double degree. and really struggled. I was doing a whole bunch of sport and athletics and just didn't know what I wanted to do, decided I didn't want to be a clinical psychologist. But, yeah, it was just sort of floundering. You know, when I came out of uni,
但我确实挂了两年大学课程，因为我根本不知道自己想做什么。所以其实我最初读的是心理学学位，双学位。并且学得很艰难。我当时参加了一堆体育和竞技运动，就是不知道自己想做什么，后来决定不想成为一名临床心理学家。但是，是的，当时就是处于那种随波逐流的状态。你知道的，当我大学毕业时……
I couldn't get a job interview. Why? Because your grades were so bad. The transcript was crap. And, yeah, I'd done all these other things, and I'd worked and I'd, you know, I had competed successfully in athletics and blah, blah, blah. But, you know, it was just on a wing and a prayer for me to go, those grades don't reflect who I really am and they're like, well, whatever.
我甚至找不到一个面试机会。为什么？因为你的成绩太糟糕了。成绩单简直一团糟。而且，是的，我做过所有这些别的事情，我工作过，而且，你知道的，我在竞技体育中取得过不错的成绩，等等等等。但是，你知道的，我当时完全是凭着侥幸心理去跟人家说，那些成绩并不能真正代表我是谁，而对方则会说，好吧，随便你。
So I took a year off and worked for a little while, traveled overseas, which was a great experience. I met some people who just didn't have the opportunities that I had, including a young woman studying economics, you know, in Turkey of all places, who was just never going to have the opportunities that I had. And so I came back and started studying again to sort of show that I could get through it and then ended up really enjoying it. So I guess, you know, at the risk of sort of waffling on a bit about it, I do think it's an important message for people to, life isn't a straight line.
所以我休学了一年，工作了一小段时间，去海外旅行了一趟，那是一次非常棒的经历。我遇到了一些人，他们没有我所拥有的那些机会，其中包括一个在土耳其那种地方学习经济学的年轻女性，她根本不可能拥有我所拥有的那些机会。所以我回来后重新开始学习，以此来证明我能把书读完，结果最后真的非常喜欢它。所以我想，你知道的，冒着唠叨太多的风险，我确实觉得这是一个很重要的信息告诉大家：生活并不是一条直线。
And as long as you're sort of learning and growing and heading in a direction that you're enjoying, you know, just keep going with it. And when it stops working, then go and do something else. It's so interesting because you have lived so many lives that, like, I wasn't there for. Like, I always think about how, you know, I've known you my entire life, but you've only known me, for the last 24 years. And there were all these things that happened before me that you have a lot of wisdom from. Like, you were my age once
只要你一直在学习、成长，并朝着一个你喜欢的方向前进，你知道的，那就继续走下去。当它不再奏效时，就去换别的做。这太有趣了，因为你经历过那么多我没有参与过的人生。比如，我总是觉得，你知道的，我认识你一辈子了，但你认识我也才仅仅过去24年。在我之前发生了那么多事情，你从中汲取了许多智慧。比如，你也曾经历过我这个年纪……
and, like, just going through the same level of, like, confusion and, like, big life changes. And I do think that's a really nice message. And I think that's one that you really always instilled in us of, like, there is not a clear blueprint for what creates a good life. You're allowed to, like, take time to figure it out. And obviously, we're all kind of doing that now. Like, what is this job?
而且，你知道的，经历著同样程度的迷茫和重大的生活转变。我确实觉得这是一个非常美好的信息。我认为这也是你一直向我们灌输的理念：对于什么才算美好生活，并没有一个清晰的蓝图。你可以花时间去摸索。显然，我们现在大家也都在这样做。比如，这份工作到底是什么？
know what this this wasn't a job when I was a kid actually it kind of was do you remember we used to always listen to the radio this american life I love that show still I feel like that was such a huge inspiration did you experience a lot of like imposter syndrome going back to uni or when you were applying for jobs again because your transcript was so not great well it's really it's really funny like on imposter syndrome yes um all through my career um and you know I've done I've chopped and changed a little bit and absolutely like I can like imposter syndrome when I started my first job because I started at federal treasury and you know to get in there was you know challenging and there were you know my cohort cohort of grads was just so impressive like in some ways I was
你知道的，这，在我小时候这可不是一份工作，其实，某种程度上也算是吧。还记得吗，我们以前总是听电台的《This American Life》（美国生活）。我至今仍然很喜欢那个节目。我觉得那真是一个巨大的灵感来源。当你重新回到大学，或者当你再次申请工作时，因为你的成绩单实在不太好看，你是否经历过很多像“冒名顶替综合征”这样的心理？好吧，这真的，真的很搞笑，关于“冒名顶替综合征”，是的，呃，贯穿了我的整个职业生涯，呃，你知道的，我稍微做过一些调整和改变。绝对的，比如当我开始第一份工作时，我就有过“冒名顶替综合征”，因为我在联邦财政部工作，而要进到那里去，你知道的，是很有挑战性的，而且，你知道的，和我同届的毕业生都太优秀了。在某种程度上，我当时……
pretty focused on what I wanted to get out of that I had a really clear objective and so in some ways I kind of ignored a whole bunch of other stuff like if I'm really honest and you know back to the question about feminism or whatever. Like I had a goal and I just ran hard at it. And in some ways, I was, you know, people sort of said to me, well, you're sort of singular focus on that opportunity, you know, was probably too much and whatever. But, you know, I don't think they would have said that if I was a man, to be honest.
相当专注于我想从中得到什么，我有一个非常明确的目标。所以在某种程度上，我选择性地忽视了一大堆别的事情，如果说实话的话。你知道的，回到关于女权主义之类的问题上。我有一个目标，然后就全力以赴地去冲。在某些方面，我，你知道的，人们会对我说，好吧，你对那个机会的单一关注，你知道的，可能太过了，诸如此类。但是，你知道的，如果我是个男的，他们肯定不会这么说，老实说。
And it worked. No, no way. So it did work. You are now. But so it was like you were doing economics, which at the time, like, a bit of a boys game. And then also business is like commerce, kind of the commerce side of it as well. Yeah, I mean, I think, sorry, I'm sorry to interrupt.
而且它成功了。真的没有。所以它确实成功了。你现在是。但当时的情况就像是你在学经济学，在当时那绝对是个“男人的游戏”。然后还有商业，就像是商科，差不多也是商业那一挂的。是的，我的意思是，抱歉，打断一下。
I also wanted to come back on the imposter syndrome and my results. When I was interviewed for treasury, the person who was interviewing me asked me precisely once about those, my results. And they said, what happened here? And I told them, and that was it. What did you say? You're just like, I just didn't know what I wanted. Yeah, I said I was doing all these other things.
我也想回到关于“冒名顶替综合征”和我的成绩这个话题上。我当时去财政部面试时，面试官针对我的那些成绩，确切地问了我一次。他们说：“这儿是怎么回事？”我告诉了他们，事情就这么过去了。你当时怎么说的？你就说：“我只是不知道自己想要什么。”是的，我说我当时在搞其他各种事情。
I had way too much on. I didn't know what I wanted. I was floundering. I came back with intent and here's the results. And that was fine. And sorry, to come back, the reason I wanted to come back to that is because fast forward a few years later when I was actually interviewing graduates for Treasury, there was a bunch of people being put on piles whose results kind of looked a bit like mine.
我身上的担子太重了。我不知道自己想要什么。我当时很迷茫。我是带着目标回来的，这就是我的成绩。这就行了。抱歉，绕回来，我之所以想回到这个话题，是因为快进到几年后，当我亲自为财政部面试毕业生时，有一堆被挑出来的简历，其成绩看起来有点像我当年那样。
And I wanted to interview one or two of them. and a few people in the room were just like, no way. And so I fessed up and said, well, you wouldn't have, I wouldn't be here. Like, don't you want to know, like there's one person in particular, I was looking at their results. And they'd gone from, you know, really poor results to just knocking out of the park. And I said, don't you want to know what happened there? Don't you, because that switch has flipped. And I want to know what's gone on and what this person is up to because that's the person I want to talk to.
而我想面试其中的一两个人。房间里的好几个人都直截了当说：“绝对不行。”所以我坦白了，说：“好吧，如果没有这种机制，我也不会坐在这里。难道你们不想知道吗？比如其中有一个人，我看了他/她的成绩。”而且他们已经从，你知道的，非常差的成绩变成了直接一鸣惊人。我说：“难道你们不想知道发生了什么吗？难道你们不……因为那个开关已经拨过去了。我想知道发生了什么以及这个人最近在忙什么，因为这正是我想要聊的人。”
And so, again, it was just a kind of an interesting life lesson, if you like. Like boys jobs, yeah, like I probably treasury, there were fair few female grads and, you know, we were very focused on making sure we continue to recruit them. So yes, it was male dominated. It was more that I had opportunities to be in really interesting meetings where everyone who was more senior was male. And that was good. I don't know, maybe this is a funny sidebar, but my name's Melinda.
所以，这也是一个非常有趣的人生教训，如果你愿意这么看的话。就像男人的工作，是的，我可能在财政部，当时有很多女性毕业生，而且，你知道的，我们非常专注于确保继续招募她们。所以是的，那是男性主导的。更多的情况是，我有机会参加一些非常有趣的会议，而所有职位比我高的人全都是男性。这挺好的。我不知道，也许这算是个有趣的插曲，但我的名字叫梅琳达（Melinda）。
People sometimes call me Mel, but at work, and particularly at Treasury, when I was at Treasury, that's when I decided people had to call me Melinda. Because Mel sounds like a male name as well? Like Mel Gibson. No, it was too dismissive. Oh, really? I went into my mail boss introduced me one day and said, oh, this is Mel. And it was just sort of, it was just a throwaway line, and I thought, I can't have that
人们有时叫我梅尔（Mel），但在工作场合，特别是在财政部时，当我还在财政部的时候，那就是我决定让大家必须叫我梅琳达的时候。因为梅尔听起来也像是个男人的名字？就像梅尔·吉布森（Mel Gibson）那样？不，因为那样太轻蔑了。哦，真的吗？有一次我的男老板把我介绍给别人，他说：“哦，这是梅尔。”那只是一种随口说出的话，我当时就想，我不能容忍这种……
throwaway line. And so I... So you needed the extra syllables for the extra legitimacy. Well, but it was just all part and parcel of how you presented. Yeah. I actually agree with that. So I just thought I can't have him just saying that the, and, you know, we work closely together, but it just felt like it was a trivialization of my introduction.
随口带过的话。所以我……所以你需要更多的音节来获得更多的正当性？好吧，但这其实全套都关系到你是如何展现自己的。是的。我其实很赞同这一点。所以我当时就觉得，我不能让他这么轻描淡写地把我介绍出去，而且，你知道的，我们工作合作很紧密，但这感觉就像是在把我的介绍流于形式、轻描淡写。
Yeah. So you're kind of like at this point in your career now where you just, I'm sure you feel pretty secure. Like you're a bit of a boss bitch. It's true though. And I know that like that word like, like she's such a boss. Like what is it? Like, your boss. It's girl boss.
是的。所以你现在在职业生涯的这个阶段，你只需，我确信你感到相当有安全感。就像你有点像是个“大老板女王（boss bitch）”。确实如此。而且我知道那个词，就像“她真像个老板（boss）”。这到底是什么？你的老板。就是“职场女强人（girl boss）”。
is like kind of funny because it's now like yeah it's used very dismissively like you're a girl boss but having come through so many stages and like I don't think you're going to retire any time soon unless you are and then that's a surprise for me what advice would you give me right now at this stage in my career and I know it's very different to what you're what you were doing at 24 like you hadn't even graduated at 24. Had you? No, you wouldn't have. You would have just gotten your master's.
这听起来挺搞笑的，因为它现在，是的，被用得非常轻蔑，就像你在被当成一个“职场女强人”。但既然你已经经历了那么多阶段，而且——我不认为你很快就会退休，除非你真的要退，那对我来说可真是个惊喜——在这个职业生涯的阶段，你会给我什么建议呢？我知道这和我24岁时你在做的事情非常不同，24岁时你甚至还没毕业呢。你毕业了吗？不，你不可能毕业。你当时应该刚拿到硕士学位。
Oh, I graduated a couple of degrees. Oh. But what would you do now? What advice would you give me at this stage? Well, can I ask a slightly different question and then, can I respond to a question you haven't asked and then I'll respond to that question? You're asking the questions now.
哦，我读了好几个学位才毕业。哦。但你现在会怎么做？在这个阶段你会给我什么建议？好吧，我能问一个稍微不同的问题，然后，我能先回答一个你没问的问题，然后再回答那个问题吗？现在是你反客为主了。
You're taking over the show. Well, you can't if you want. No, I'm joking. You can totally do that. No, the one thing. Just some reference to sort of being the sort of boss pitch language or whatever or label. Girl boss. Or whatever you want to call.
你接管节目了。好吧，如果你想的话，也可以。不，我开玩笑的。你完全可以这么做。不，有一件事。只是提到关于“职场女强人”这种语言或标签什么的。职场女强人。或者你想怎么叫都行。
Like I do, I think, I did want to say there's one thing I've really enjoyed about leading an organisation is being able to sort of set the tone and the values. And I think people can think about a whole bunch of things that being a CEO means or whatever. And there's a lot of, there's different responsibilities. But probably the one thing I didn't really think about and underestimate. was that was the sense of satisfaction that you get out of kind of being able to set the tone for an organisation. Yeah.
就像我一样，我觉得，我确实想说，领导一个组织让我真正享受的一点，就是能够去设定基调和价值观。我认为人们可以从很多方面去理解CEO意味着什么，诸如此类。这里面有很多不同的责任。但可能有一件事是我没有真正想到并严重低估的……那就是你能从为整个组织设定基调这件事中获得的满足感。是的。
And I think the reason it's, I'm kind of, I'm using as a bit of a segue into your question because I think it's like, it's, it's caused me to sort of reflect on how you set your tone through your career. And, and I guess that's, that would be my kind of advice, I guess, is to, you know, to think about, you know, who you are and what sort of. person you want to be through the work that you do. And to not be necessarily confined by thinking about a particular role or a particular point in your career, but to, you know, think about the things that you enjoy doing because you do them well and because you can have an impact,
我觉得我之所以把它当作一个切入点来回答你的问题，是因为我觉得，它引发了我对你在职业生涯中如何设定基调的反思，而且，我想，这也就是我的建议吧——去思考，你知道的，你自己是谁，以及你想通过你所做的工作成为什么样的人。不要一定被局限在思考某个特定的职位或职业生涯的某个特定节点上，而是要去思考那些你喜欢做的事情，因为你擅长做它们，并且因为它们能产生影响。
whatever that is and just that sort of tone and the values, the way you want to live your life, to find ways to live that through work. And it's probably something that you gain a confidence to be able to do through your career. And when I look back, you know, it's probably one of the things you feel less confident doing when you're, you know, early on in a job or whatever that you sort of feel sometimes you have to behave a particular way or be in a particular role. And, you know, I was a company director at a very young age. I was the only woman on the first boardser I joined. And there's certainly a lot of pressure to sort of be the persona of that.
无论那是什么，只要找到那种基调、价值观以及你想要的生活方式，并在工作中将其实践出来。这可能是你在职业生涯中逐渐获得信心才能做到的一点。当我回首往事时，你知道的，这很可能是你在刚开始工作或身处某种职位时，最缺乏自信去做的事情之一——你有时会觉得自己必须表现得像某种特定的人，或者在某个特定的职位上扮演好某种角色。而且，你知道的，我很年轻的时候就当过公司董事。我是我加入的第一块董事会上唯一的女性。而且扮演好那种人设确实面临着很大的压力。我想这大概就是我的建议。如果你能找到一种比我更快做到这一点的方法，那就是我的建议。
And I guess that's probably my bit of advice. If you can find a way to do that faster than I did, that would be my advice. Oh, to find, like, your mission. But also just to be who you are and to know that that's, you know, you don't have to be the persona. You don't have to perform that role in the way other people have performed that role or be that person. And so it's just trying to be true to who you are as a person and bring that into your work is probably what I'd put on the table. Thanks, Mom.
哦，去找到，比如你的使命。但同时也仅仅是做你自己，并知道那就是，你知道的，你不必去维持那种人设。你不必像其他人那样去扮演那个角色，也不必成为那样的人。所以，努力对真实的自我保持忠诚，并把这种真实带入到你的工作中，这可能就是我想摆到台面上来的建议。谢谢妈妈。
I appreciate the advice. Now, I think that's all the questions that I have. Are there any more questions you would like to ask yourself? If you feel the need. No, no, no, that's it. Yeah, that's good. I'm glad. I feel like we covered a lot of bases here.
我很感激这个建议。好了，我想这就是我所有的全部问题了。你还有什么想问自己的问题吗？如果你觉得有必要的话。不，不，不，就这样吧。对，挺好的。我很欣慰。我觉得我们今天聊了很多方面。
We talked about motherhood. We talked about feminism. We talked about how you were a terrible parent and everything I have to blame you for, just kidding. Nothing was the answer. So thank you so much for coming on. Absolute pleasure. I could think of nothing else I'd rather be doing.
我们聊了为人母亲。我们聊了女权主义。我们聊了你曾经是个糟糕的家长以及我所有必须怪你的地方，开玩笑的。答案是什么都没有。所以非常感谢你能来做客。我的荣幸。我想不出还有什么比这更让我愿意做的事了。
Yeah. Well, I'll... That's so sweet. Why did that make me embarrassed? I'm like, oh, thanks, Mom. No, it was actually so nice, and I feel like it's so nice that we'll have this for, like it will be on the internet for a while, and we can listen back to this when I'm thinking about putting you in a home or something.
是的。好吧，我……这太甜了。为什么这让我感到尴尬？我心想，哦，谢谢妈妈。不，其实真的太美好了，而且我觉得拥有这段录音真的很棒，因为这会在互联网上保留一段时间，等以后我在考虑把你送进养老院的时候，我还可以回听这个。
Oh, I remember. You can just play it on repeat and I'll feel happy. Oh, I'm not going to put you in a home. Do you want to be put in a home? Depends. Depends. You may want to put me in a home. No, I won't for as long as possible.
哦，我记下了。你到时候只要循环播放它，我就会觉得很开心。哦，我才不会把你送进养老院呢。你想被送进养老院吗？这得看情况。看情况。你可能还真想把我送进养老院。不，只要有可能，我才不会呢。
In the meantime, I'm looking forward to coming. and sleeping on your couch tomorrow. Oh my gosh, yeah, my mom's coming to stay in my new place tomorrow. It's very comfy. I actually had a lie down on it before. I tested it for you. Perfect. I can't believe I'm making you sleep on the couch.
在此期间，我很期待明天去……睡在你的沙发上。哦天哪，对啊，我妈明天要来我的新地方住。那沙发很舒服的。我之前其实在上面躺过。我为你测试过了。完美。真不敢相信我竟然让你睡沙发。
But unfortunately, the bed's taken. Well, thank you again for coming on, as always. If you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. Share it with a friend if they would like to hear it. And if you have any further episode suggestions, questions for my girl boss mom, please feel free to DME on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast or my personal at Gemma Spag. And we will be back next week for another episode. 2%.
但很不巧，床已经有人占了。好吧，再次感谢你来做客，一如既往。如果你喜欢这一集，请随时在苹果播客、Spotify或你现在收听的任何地方留下五星好评。如果你的朋友也想听，请分享给他们。如果你还有任何关于节目的进一步建议、或者想问我这位“女强人老妈”的问题，请随时在Instagram上私信我，账号是That Psychology Podcast或者我的个人账号Gemma Spag。我们下周将带着另一集节目回归。《2%》。
That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会迎来一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。
That's TWO%. On the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
就在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方。在《Look Back At It》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是个大日子。84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。
Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过这段日子的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及我们最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔畅谈80年代。那是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back At It》。这是一个IHeart播客。人类保证。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。